With a rarified (or super thin) atmosphere
looking at the stars from Mars must be incredible!
But at night on Mars, there's also another
source of light ... the atmosphere of the
Red Planet is literally glowing!
Howdy glow worms, this is DNews, and I'm Trace.
Nightglow is the tendency for the atmosphere
of a planet to glow in complete absence of
external light.
This bizarre effect was spotted in mid-2016
by MAVEN.
The Mars Atmosphere and Volatile EvolutioN
mission was sent to orbit Mars to ascertain
how Mars was stripped of its ancient atmosphere.
But, while analyzing ultraviolet pictures
scientists spotted this nightglow in the swirling
high-altitude air of our rust-colored neighbor…
Okay first, MAVEN has found that the sun's
constant barrage of energy from it's nuclear
reactions have slowly stripped the atmosphere
of the planet to it's current level, 100 to
150 times thinner than our on Earth.
That same stripping of the atmosphere is causing
the nightglow that MAVEN spotted!
When ultraviolet light from the sun hits the
"leading edge" of the planet the energy in
the particles break down carbon dioxide, nitrogen
and oxygen which are all floating around in
the Martian sky.
This is called photodissociation.
The now-broken-up particles, are then carried
on high altitude winds all around the planet.
Once they reach the nightside of Mars (away
from UV light), those free nitrogen and oxygen
atoms interact -- combining to form nitric
oxide between 60 and 100 kilometers above
the dusty surface [. When they do that, they
release energy, causing this nightglow!
It's basically the same idea used for glow-in-the-dark
toys or glowsticks!
Scientists are excited because it's very difficult
to map the movement of the Martian atmosphere!
Taking "pictures" of this glow can help scientists
determine what's happening down there throughout
the Mars year.
They can see how air moves in different Mars
seasons, better understand the planet's cloud
formations, and thanks to ozone formation,
find water molecules.
To be honest, nightglow is completely normal,
and Mars isn't the only planet that has it…
it's been seen on Venus, and a little planet
you may have heard of, Eeeahhrth?!
Just like on Mars, Earth's nightglow is caused
by chemical reactions in the upper atmosphere,
between 85 and 95 kilometers up.
And just like on Mars this glow is very faint;
NASA's Earth Observatory says the glow on
our planet is about a billionth as bright
as sunlight.
So, it's very hard to see, but it's not invisible.
A 2005 study in Astroparticle Physics found
about 564 photons per meter squared, per second,
over the Mediterranean Sea.
And, if you were on the International Space
Station looking sideways at the atmosphere
you can see a faint glow… that's Earth's
nightglow!
We know a bit more about our own nightglow
-- for example, just like on Mars, the solar
wind photo dissociates molecules in our upper
atmosphere, and when they recombine they release
energy as green, blue, yellow, and red light:
oxygen glows green or blue, sodium yellowish,
and hydroxls, or OH molecules glow red.
Science is beautiful, ain't it?
Nightglow is just another byproduct of the
sun's neverending assault on our atmosphere,
and the atmosphere of other planets in our
solar system.
What a warm nuclear ball of awesome.
Worried that the constant barrage of solar
energy is actually going to steal our atmosphere?
Can we run out of oxygen!?
Check out this video with my girl Julia for
more on that.
And what is your favorite science topic?
Space?
Environment?
Animals? Physics?!
Tell us in the comments.
Thanks for watching!
Please subscribe so you get more DNews.